[Music]
so
okay having
looked at the various relationships
which can be used for the
design of our irrigation system
we look at another aspect
of the
system design
let's put a question to ourselves that
was the guarantee
that the parameters which you have
obtained from those relationships
are those the valid parameters when you
will be applying those parameters in the
field
so
quite often is required that we should
check those parameters
and try to uh
define some procedure by which you can
check those parameters
we had seen that in the case of border
irrigation design also that we had gone
in further
the field trials or field evaluation
similarly in this case also
we can adopt
a similar procedure
to
check those parameters which we have
obtained
whether those parameters are
close to the parameters which you
actually obtain through the field trials
if they are
well and good
if they are not
then you will have to
revise some of those parameters
depending on what are the actual
conditions because many times what is
the reason behind
if you look at the reason behind
you are trying to
use the relationships
which
which represent the conditions in the
field
so that representation if it is faulty
or if it is not
is always dependent on some observations
which you have made at some discrete
points in the
field
if those are not
proper
then
you might get some
some
parameters which are not representative
parameters
because many times you might be
you might be basing all your
criteria
on the
the infiltration
observations which you have made
those observations they belong to
certain point locations in the field
so when you do the trial run
you will be able to verify those
parameters so let's have a look at
the field trial verification procedures
of some of the design parameters
on the case of
furrow
irrigation the
first thing which you want to
find out is that what is the maximum
stream size which should be
taken
and
you have used this relationship to find
out that
q maximum
having obtained this q maximum
now you set up
a length
in the field
which is representative length of the
the furrow field
and select around
four to five furrows
for example if you have
this is your
total field
having
different photos
you can select some segment
maybe somewhere here
where you can
you have the upstream and there's the
downstream end
where you are making the
measurements
and then you select some of the photos
so you have you have selected a
representative segment of the
total field
and
this segment
has a portion of the field where you
will be making the observations
so so as to check the various design
parameters
now the queue maximum which we have
obtained
so let us assume that you have
selected four photos
and
you have a q maximum
which you know
which is a desirable stream size which
you obtained from the relationship
now select
four different
stream sizes
in such a way that
some of them are
more than q
maxima and some of them
are less chance
the q maximum value
the one which is
less
you try to select
one out of this
which hardly
which may not be able to
even reach the
downstream end of the field
so it's so low you are trying to select
those stream sizes which are extreme
scenes stream sizes
the one which is
very low and
on this side you might
select one which is
definitely
erosive
so as
to have a range of these stream sizes
because you want to you want to
make the observations that how
the
the movement of water will behave with
respect to these different ranges of the
stream size
so once you have
selected the same sizes
you make the observations
the observations
are only made in terms of the elapsed
time
but how the waterfront moves from the
upstream
end of the furrow to the downstream end
so you plot these
with respect to the distance
down the furrow
meters
this is in
minutes
depending on what sizes you have
selected
you might find that you are once you
plot those
you will get a
family of these
advanced curves
belong to different
stream sizes
for example this is
if you take this as the
you might now be able to observe one
if you have
many of them
you might
out of these you might
know that which is the one
which is the maximum
allowable stream size
because you want to select one
which is non-erosive
okay that you can call
as the maximum
allowable stream size
here
you will have all these
stream sizes will be
this will be more than
q maximum if we call this as the q
maximum now you can also match that
whether the q maximum which you have
obtained
from the relationship from the empirical
relationship does it match with the
allowable maximum
as per the field conditions or not
so that's the first check
so if you find that that
maximum allowable is different
choose that as the maximum allowable
and the others now
these are the sizes which are
greater than q maximum and they'll be
will be creating
erosion
on the field
and on this side of the
this maximum allowable these are the
stream sizes which are
less than q maximum
and they are
non-erosive
at the same time
they are of course non-erosive but we
have seen that to have
less of de-percolation
you should try to have the maximum
stream size
the fpr ratio which we have seen
we can we have seen the justification
now
having
obtained this family of the curves
now
this family of curve is with respect to
unknown
slope
and
non-q values
you can always
use iterative procedures to find out
what is the
the length to be adopted
and what is the corresponding
time of advance
to show you the
how you do the use the iteration to find
out
which are the proper parameters
let's take one
case
where you have been given
the given data is that q maximum
as
0.4
liters per second
the slope
of the field is
also given
and
the family curve
or the properties of the soil
in terms of the family curve
as known
so once the family curve is known you
know all that
the coefficients
a b and c
so now
as a first trial
you have to make
trial runs assume
a length
of the field let's say
we assume
100 meter land
let's call this as the
first trial
you can evaluate beta
since we know the values of
all these
parameters
g is known since the family curve is
known
and
x is 100 meters that's what we have
taken as the segment of the length so x
is basically
uh
the length of the field considered
does the value of g
with respect to the family curve
into
100 meters and q is known to be 4 liters
per second
0 0 5
to the power 0.5
and this is
2.13
now with this
beat off
you can find out what is the
advanced time
i'll call
it t1 because this is the first trial
this is given as
all these relationships we have seen
earlier
so
this is what this will evaluate to be
into
exponent
of beta is 2.13
this is
and then 10 minutes
having found this
advanced time
let me
let me assume that when once i have
found out the
the stream size
if the stream size is 0.4
i have taken
these
stream sizes to be i have chosen these
stream sizes for which the family curves
have been
plotted
and these belong to
these values
0.15 liters per second point three point
four five point six
okay
so let's let's assume that these belong
to the the given case which we have
just taken
and let's
give some values to
a distance
and so on i'm just trying to sketch it
in a rough manner
and the time
elapsed time
is from
0 to 500 minutes
now
in the first case
when i
i have found that the
advanced time
is 110 minutes
so for that case
i find out
for this advanced time
and the distance i know the distance
taken is
100 meters
if this is the 100 meter distance here
i try to project it
and if this belongs to
110 minutes
i find that this
point
lies
much below the
the maximum allowable stream size
and this point
with respect to these two parameters
if i take 100
meters as the length of the field
and for which
the advanced time with respect to
the given parameters
is 110 minutes
then
this
point lies
below this
the maximum allowable
which suggests that
if you use these parameters you are
going to get
the erosive conditions
so that means either
the length is not proper
or
the synth length is dependent on the
advanced time
or the advanced time is dependent on the
length
is the either way they are both
interconnected
so i can take
another length
as a second trial that means this
particular
condition is not
acceptable
i take the second trial
and assume a length
which is
larger than the previous case
take a length of 140 meters
now for 140 meters length meter
gets over evaluated to
sorry 2.98
and
the corresponding advanced time
is
minutes
again
if i get back to this
for 140
meter
i
project a
vertical line from here
and on this side
the
elapsed time is 300 something 362.
if this is the point here for 362.
i project it
and you are getting a point
which is slightly above the
the maximum discharge
um
curve the maximum logarithmic discharge
curve
so this shows that
we have achieved a condition now with
respect to these two
length of 140
and the the
resultant advanced time is 362 minutes
so this gives you a condition
where you can
you will
have a situation where the erosion is
not a problem
but you might be getting
efficiency which is not as much as
achievable
it's not an optimum efficiency the
optimum efficiency you will get
when you
when you you will be able to closer to
the maximum allowable stream size
so you can
if you feel that you have come quite
close to this with the respect to these
parameters is fine otherwise you can
have another child
where you can still improve upon
take a third trial where you improve on
the length
and
you feel that you have taken a length
which is
more than the desirable
you can take it
to be
less than the previous case
and have another iteration
where
this case beta is 2.66 and
the
advanced time works out to be 235
minutes
now this
advanced time versus
the length
combination
it falls quite close to the
q maximum
and
now you can
you can say that you have achieved
a situation which is
desirable and at this at this juncture
you now compare the parameters which are
obtained here
with respect to the parameters which you
obtained
by the
the other
the equations which have been provided
and that comparison will give you an
insight into whether
the results which you obtained through
the
the procedural steps
using the procedure which you have
studied in the last class
how close they are to the actual
conditions
so if they are very far
they are far apart you might have to
make some adjustments
so once in a way it is always better to
keep track of these
these parameters and
wet those parameters
try to check those parameters
don't keep on blindly using those
parameters that is the main main reason
of having these
trial
evaluation runs for different systems we
have seen in the case of border
and this also even similarly in the case
of level basin which you are going to
consider
next
the procedures remain same only the
expressions the way you have to conduct
the trial runs
they will change
okay
so with that we
conclude this
topic
on the
furrow education system
and we will move on to the
the next
topic which is
a topic of level basin system
if you have any question i can answer
that at this juncture
we won't spend much time on the level
basin system because
is
quite same
procedures
as we have done in the case of border
irrigation system
only with very small minor differences
and i'll quickly go through this
particular subject
a topic which
is a
related topic
and try to bring out those differences
which are considered in the
evaluation and the design of this
level basin system
if you remember we have
discussed earlier
that
the level basin
is a special case of
the border
only difference is the level basin
they are not having any slope
they are
level areas
without
slope
they're relatively small in size
and what you are doing
the suitability in terms of the
suitability
they are suitable
far
low to moderate
and take soils
so for those soils where
the infiltration rates are
relatively
lower
you can use you can make use of this
system
the
shapes of the fields are normally
rectangular but the sizes are not the
lengths are not
as big as
you have in the case of border
derivation
because of the fact that
you are trying to flood these areas
now the reason is that you want to do
the flooding in these small
basins
so that you can
let the water stand for a long period
so as to have
the
the available infiltration opportunity
time
to be there so as to have the desired
desired infiltration
take place in the field
because
we have just said that the
the
infiltration rates of these soils are
very low if you let the water pass over
the surface of the soil
the
amount of time which is available for
the infiltration
is very small
and since the infiltration rates are
very low it needs a very long time for
infiltration
so that is the reason that the
shape of the basin
and the size of the basin
has been reduced the
the slopes are not given so that you can
flood the area
you can check the water within the area
that is the idea if you create slopes
then you will find that
the lower portions of the let me
elaborate this point that
if i have
a field which is having slope
if you want to
supply a depth of water
and
you try to trap this water it will get
accumulated only into the lower area so
you have to have a
relatively
level
surface
on which you can
now you can
establish a depth of water
and the depth of water will depend on
what is the ridge size
what is the height of the edge which are
created
in
creating these
these basins
will come to that that is also a
parameter which has to be considered in
the designs
so
this particular method
from that angle is
is created for some special
purpose
or some special circumstances but with
respect to the type of crops which can
be grown
we have already considered that
in this particular
method in the czech basin method or the
level basin method
the
crops
there's hardly any crop which cannot be
grown in this even those crops which are
not
suitable to be known with any other
method
example the rice
or the jute which need
the water inundated water which need the
standing water they also
are
used with this method
other all the other methods even the
orchards
they are also irrigated using this
method where you are
creating the conditions where you are
taking care of each individual plant
by having a ring method which you had
considered
so
we have discussed that earlier also and
let's
let's set this juncture try to look into
the various
formulations which have been considered
for
the design of these
systems
and this case also as we have seen in
the previous
cases
that there are some
relationships
which are based on
experience
and
the
even the field trials
and these relationships are ultimately
given in the form of
a very simple
chart
which becomes the starting
the starting parameters of the design
you can always use them as the
thumb rules or as the
values which are recommended values
so in this case
there is one
that they are presented in different
different
forms
and one
form which i am trying to express here
is the chart given in terms of the flow
rate
in liters per second and for different
soil type
the soil type vary from
sand
to sandy long to clay long
so
clay
and you are given the area of the
basin
and hectares
for different
forage and for different
soils
so i'll only pick up some of the
values for some in
intermediate
stream sizes
and give you the variation that how much
variation in
size can take place
which is the recommended
sizes for
all these different types of soils
let me say that this is
270.
now you can see
the variation
when you have very small stream size
within the same uh
the same stream size when you go from
one extreme of the soil type to the
other extreme
the area can vary
by around
10 times
same is true in this case also
and for different seam sizes for the
same soil
there's still a lot of variation in the
area which can be used for the
level basin
besides this
this this will give you a
reasonably good
starting parameters of the
design
but you can always
if you have more data available you can
go in for the detailed design which is
dependent on the hydraulic relationships
which we have been using for other
methods
the relationships basically used in this
these designs
are the soil characteristics
which we have seen
and
the manning's
equation which have been used very often
because with the assumption that
the
we are considering
a channel flow which is a very wide
channel with a very small depth
as the assumption made
because basically the manning's equation
is for channel flow
so let's look at the hydraulic
relationship
which we can use for the case of
level basin
this equation is still valid
for the
net depth of
infiltration
which is
which we have
used very often so using this equation
you can
always
get the time of infiltration
to have this much net depth of
infiltration
what is the
the desirable time of infiltration
can be obtained from
the same relationship
once we have this
tn available
now we use the fpr's
the fractional advanced ratio
and the fracture advance ratio
is
given for
this is basically
the
affair the way we are defined as the
ratio of
advanced time by the
net time
the fps
varies with respect to the
the distribution pattern efficiency
or
you can also say that the distribution
pattern efficiency is dependent on
affair and for different
distribution pattern efficiencies
far
value
has been computed and given in this
table
similarly for
other efficiencies
you have
now this is
something which is available either in
this form
or
even in a graphical representation is
one of the same thing even there's a
the equation which is available
to uh
find out
the distribution pattern efficiency
knowing the affairs
and this equation is a
regression equation
which you can
make note of
and 2
dt by tn
to the power
0.5
this is 0.5 here
where
it is
and
percentage as in this
once you
either know your
t n
to the power 0.5
i'm sorry
as
i'll write with this
is it visible now
now
there can be different
situations
in one case
you might select a ed
that you want to
you don't want to have a
distribution pattern efficiency below a
particular level
so in that case
you fix your id
and you can find out what will be the
the far possible
for that id
so if that is the situation
then
you know your affair
if far is
known
you can
you can know the affair
or in other words
you know this ratio
this you can
find out
from the table
depending on the acceptable
distribution pattern efficiency
once you know this
you can now evaluate
t t because
t n is known
and
the far is known
okay
so knowing therefore
the advanced time can also be
evaluated
then there is a relationship between
the
the time of advance
and the length
and
the stream size
now in this case let me tell you that
the stream size which we use
is not the stream size
for the total strip we use per unit
strip so the unit stream size which you
can
say is the
cube divided by the width of the
basin
and
this will be in
meter cube per seconds per meter
width
or meter per second
that is what we call the unit
stream size
and this length is
given in terms of the unit stream size
and the advanced time
and the other parameters of
the family curve
this is lying by
16.
and
advanced time by
3 by 60.
so that's the expression which is
used
to find out the length of the
basin
and this
the n value
n value is the same
as we had used for the border irrigation
system i had given you the three n
values
which are representative of three
conditions
the small this value was for smooth bare
soil
surface
point one
is taken as the when the when you have
small grain drill
rows
parallel to the bottle strip
and if you have
a dense crop or when the rows are
drilled across the border strip
then you have
more resistance the n value is 0.25 the
same and values or similar n values are
chosen for
if this is a similar situation the
difference is not much
the only difference is that you have
the flat areas
besides this you will also be interested
in knowing what is the cutoff
time
the
time to cut off
which we are calling as
tco
the relationship
used for the time to cut off
all these quantities you are
now quite
aware of
the unit
stream size
the distribution pattern efficiency
the length
and the net depth of infiltration
and this
the
ea is assumed to be 100
the application efficiency
so if the application efficiency is
assumed to be hundred percent then this
is the expression
otherwise
if the application efficiency is less
than hundred percent
which is normally not the case in the
case of surface irrigation systems
but if it is if you
are certain that is not hundred percent
then you can use
the expression which is
giving
a also
okay
that'll be the device expression
if
your ear is not 100
then lastly we are also
interested in knowing that what is the
maximum
depth of
flow on the basin
this maximum depth of flow in the basin
has to find out the requirement of the
ridge
and normally the
ridge size
is approximately 1.25 times
the
the maximum if we
call this
maximum depth as the maximum
so you can compute the
the maximum
using this expression
this expression used for
obtaining the d maximum
and the maximum
will be
millimeters
now here
there's one
requirement that
there might be a situation when
the
advanced time is
more than
the cutoff time
if
that is the situation which can which
can only happen in the case of
level basins
so if that is the situation
then you must
and this
equation of t max you must
replace tco with
dt
so in this expression
which is for the
nd max expression
okay
that will have to take care that if your
time of
advances happens to be more than the
the
time of cutoff
then
this will be the governing time to
compute the d maximum which is quite
understandable
so that is what
gives us
all the parameters which we are
interested in
and similarly in this case also you can
go in for the trial runs and
check the parameters as we have
suggested in the previous two cases
so with that
i
will conclude
the topic of
irrigation methods using the surface
irrigation
or the
gravity irrigation flow
and then in the next class
we'll proceed with
the design
of other two methods
the sprinkler irrigation and the
depletion system
okay
any question i want to uh
answer this juncture
the question is that is there any thumb
rule for the basin method
the thumb rule in terms of this is the
table which we have
just looked at
i had given you some values of that
table
that was basically a thumb rule
uh it can be converted into a thumb rule
in the sense that
this thumb rule all the thumb rules
which you
normally
formulate
they are
having lot of experience behind them
so this
can be taken as a thumb rule
where
if you know the stream size because
normally what parameters are available
to you
the constraints the constrained
parameters are
the quantity of
stream size or the rate of stream size
which is
the stream size which is
available to a farmer at a particular
location
if that is known
and
we also know in general what are the
the type of soil which are
prevalent there in that field
then he can
use this as a thumb rule that what is
the size of the
the basin which he should
adopt so as to get a reasonably good
efficiency
so this is this is nothing but a thumb
rule it can be taken as a thumb rule
okay
thank you
[Music]
so
you